I might start my own diet
fat go on JRE go on the Rog and
experience be like dude look I'm going
to eat like a polar bear now it's the
largest land predator I want to be Alpha
I want to be elite I'm going to eat like
a polar bear I'm only eating four or
five days I'm going to eat 100 pounds at
a time which a polar bear can of just
blubber I eat seal Hey Joe just went to
the market here I've got seal blubber
here do you mind if I just kind of eat
this while we record this is my fourth
day just happens to be the day we're
recording so I'm going to eat this now
it's very elite uh that I'm going to
pass out for 20 hours pretty much
basically I'm a polar bear Joe uh yeah
got it up there and yeah so now I'll
just I'll pound this blubber and then
I'll pass out 20 hours four or five days
I'll stay away from my family it's part
of my diet is staying away from my
family Joe it's part of my diet is just
not talking to my wife my Cub so this a
polar bear diet it's gonna take off it's
gonna take off